i'm sasha larkin a captain with the las
vegas metropolitan police department
i'm here to bring you the preliminary
details as we know them so far
on an in-custody death that occurred
today monday october 19
2020. today at approximately 1 30 pm
a call for service came in from the 5500
block of west sahara
at a car dealership the employee who is
our person reporting
stated that an unidentified black male
adult had entered the store
and was rambling incoherently and he
began
assaulting striking numerous employees
inside the business
at that point a couple employees and
some citizens
grabbed the subject and took him to the
ground and called 9-1-1
as police arrived they saw the subject
the unidentified black male adult in his
early 30s
on the ground being held down by the
citizens and employees of the business
the officers went over placed the
subject
into handcuffs they quickly rolled him
to his side
into what we call the recovery position
and immediately checked his breathing
the officers noticed right away that his
breathing was labored
and inconsistent and they immediately
summoned for medical to expedite
a few minutes later medical arrived and
unfortunately
they pronounced the subject deceased
these details are very preliminary as
the investigation is still unfolding
thank you how are the employees
they're okay they're okay uh the one of
them had to go to the hospital
and seek medical attention um
we don't have any of those details yet
we're looking into that
at the time
we're not sure yet we're not sure if the
subject was passed before we got there
or after
is it in this show i'm that i'm not sure
when he was attacking the employees what
did he he said
with his hands did he have a weapon he
had an unknown
bag in his hand does the subject have an
identification
we're not sure yet he's not been
identified yet
thank you 30s
early 30s we are estimating
thank you